all right new rule now that they've
wrestled his approval rating down to the
basement and grabbed both houses of
Congress Republicans must explain why
this guy keeps kicking your ass it's
like one of those action movies where
you tie the hero up and chained him to a
chair and then he hunt headbutt you
unconscious and gets up and leaves a
note sign Django here Oh Andrew Caldwell
who in a video that when a video that
went viral last week testified in church
I'm not gay no more needs to inform his
wardrobe niro and these partisan times
teddy bear paradise a real name the
Houston woman who was sentenced this
week for sending threatening letters to
Obama and who in 2008 pled guilty to
threatening to kill Bush must be held up
as an example of bipartisanship
to many Americans today just bluntly
follow their party but not teddybear
paradise she carefully ways all the
voices in her head and holds both
parties accountable by threatening to
stab them new rule now that we know that
cured Ebola patients can have infectious
semen for months afterwards trojan must
come out with a hazmat condom because
there's nothing more annoying make a
one-night stand and waking up with AIDS
and of all
new rule nobody wants your homemade
handcrafted Christmas present
if your gift involve the use of a glue
gun pinking shears yarn or beads I don't
want it you want to make me something
make me a garbage can to throw all your
other presents oh look I made you a
tablet case out of an old pair of jeans
great now my iPad smells like ass